faze clan two hype rdc
amp the biggest creators compete in the
ultimate game of dodgeball for a 250
000 dollar prize scanning the qr code to
rep your team and watch the h08 showdown
dodgeball tourney live this friday at
eight o'clock eastern
on house of highlights youtube channel
watch that it's that time it's time
oh for the night presented by
no one come on ernie
unsullied by sponsorship since 1989.
thank you dr o'neal so uh given that
promo that we just did for the house of
highlights dodgeball
the guys upstairs thought it would be a
good idea for us to generate some more
interest in it by
uh i guess doing some type of dodge ball
here in the studio i don't know i mean i
don't really not familiar with the rules
but we don't know the rules yeah but we
do
play yeah but we do have people that we
can throw at also y'all don't have a
dodge ball in the suburbs no
i haven't i've i've seen the movie dodge
yeah do y'all play hops
meaning if the ball hits the floor and
then hit you you're right no it's got a
hitch in the air it's got engineer okay
yeah hops
no ops and if you catch it if i catch
yours then you're out until
until unless yeah unless you hit one of
our guys then you're back in here we go
yeah
but hold on well y'all got too much time
on your hand knowing all the dodgeball
rules what's that
since there's two of us but you're two
hits each but do we get no no one
hitting out
no no we're not i mean
are we not playing earn it your
microphone is all
not like we're not like we're staying
here for the rest why do you take your
jacket off why are you trying to throw
it hard at me
what if i'm going to throw them all
right so when who's there yeah we going
let's go wait wait wait wait wait wait
no it's on all right
hold on well i'm taking my jacket off
hit me with a bottle
oh chuck's out for a minute chuck you're
out for a second
you over the line already you know what
a lot let me chuck you out
i got to catch one i got to catch one
okay chuck's out don't worry about it i
got to catch one
i got to keep
[Laughter]
okay
oh
[Applause]
oh my gosh chuck felt like a girl man
oh that's why i lost look who i was
playing with man y'all should put me
with shaq man yeah what's up with that
buckster i know that's in the shoulder
should have put me with shot i got him i
got